hey you know Ned how are you guys doing
I hope you're all doing well I asked you
guys what video I should make today and
a lot of you guys wanted me to talk
about the Oscars but I didn't actually
watch the Oscars because watching The
Amazing Race supporting Team YouTube go
make it and Joey so the only thing that
I really know that happened at the
Oscars is Jennifer Lawrence fell the PES
part about Jennifer Lawrence is she
actually looked good falling and we tell
you what guys if any of you even
remotely tried to make fun of her let me
tell you what they'll put on a pair of
heels pull it on a big freakin dress and
try to walk in it and then get back to
me and Jennifer you'd let us know how
that works out for you because it's
probably not very working very well but
one of my biggest fears is falling so
would she fell well I didn't actually
see alive so I watched it two days later
I was like no I just want to catch you
even last week when I was presenting at
the streamys the only thing I was
thinking while I was walking out on that
stage was don't fall don't fall don't
fall don't fall don't fall don't fall
even if your dress falls down doesn't
matter just don't you call but the
ironic part in all of this is I'm a
really good father Paul er I really know
how I figured out that this was a talent
of mine but back when I was in high
school I got detention for falling in
the cafeteria inciting a riot
Iran's all knew that I was really good
at following so they're like hey I just
need to be so funny if you tripped in
the lunchroom still do tray everywhere
apparently someone told on me and told
the principal that Justine is really
good at falling and she did it on
purpose so whoever that was I will never
forgive you to this day even out an old
video on YouTube of me falling in a
grocery store now I'm gonna give you a
little slow-mo fault and please if you
try this and you get hurt it's not my
fault so kids don't try this at home I'm
not liable for your injuries
[Music]
okay well that was just carpet so let's
maybe take it outside a little bit of
concrete oh now let's take it into a
public establishment so if you guys
liked my balls please be sure to like
this video and subscribe for more videos
that probably won't involve falling they
really never know what I'm gonna post
here let me know if you guys have any
weird talents just leave them in the
comments below or tweet them to me and
I'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]